apex season 6 hitman vr and cyberpunk
it's all going down this thursday i'm
lucy and here are the biggest gaming
news stories from thursday august 6th
[Music]
apex season six is right around the
corner adding a brand new legend
weapon and more season six will kick off
on august 18th
and we'll introduce a new legend named
rampart she's an expert modder who made
her name in underground fight clubs
talks big and has the ballistics to back
it up there'll also be a new weapon the
volt smg which you might recognize if
you've played titanfall
there'll be a new crafting system new
cosmetics called hollow sprays
and of course there'll be a brand new
battle pass while we don't know exactly
what rampart's abilities are
just yet make sure you keep your eyes
peeled to gamespot because we're going
to be breaking that trailer down
and trying to unravel the mystery i
wonder if rampart is woody harrelson's
main
[Music]
all right samurai we've got a live
stream to watch
that's right we're getting more
cyberpunk 2077 news
this monday with cd projekt red
announcing that their next
night city wire live stream will air on
august 10th
at 9am pt that's noon et this stream
will focus on
life paths weapons and the game's
soundtrack in particular
how the band refused were transformed
into samurai
we'll have the stream right here on
youtube.com gamespot
but if you're really interested in
cyberpunk keep your eyes peeled for some
features that we have
right now we've got one up about the
origins of night city the worst place to
live in america
but we're also working on one about
johnny silverhand kiana reeves himself
today's state of play gave us a good
look at some gameplay from upcoming
titles like crash 4
godfall and of course bug snacks but the
most intriguing revelation from today's
stream
vr is coming to hitman nothing says
immersion like a first
person view and hitman 3 is going to
have psvr support that puts you
in the shoes of agent 47. if you already
own hitman and hitman 2 and buy hitman 3
then you'll get all those missions in
one package and
you'll also get vr support for them too
honestly
didn't see it coming but i guess that's
what you say about the best assassins
those are the biggest stories from today
we'll be back again on monday
playful may be over but head over to
store.gamespot.com to pick up some sweet
merch
with all proceeds going to black lives
matter and direct relief until the end
of the month
i'm on twitter at lucy james games and
we'll be back again on monday with all
the biggest news stories
[Music]
you